ils viennent ici tous les jours pour
certains pour d'autres quelques heures
par semaine à méré depuis maintenant
deux ans et demi le 50 corps working
accueille une cinquantaine de
travailleurs d'un nouveau genre
un nouveau mode de travail que souhaite
déployer le gouvernement pour preuve la
visite la semaine dernière de la
ministre du travail développer des
espaces de coworking
en france c'est une bonne manière de
permettre ce que ce à quoi aspire 61 %
de nos concitoyens
c'est à dire de faire du télétravail et
en même temps d'avoir cette valeur
ajoutée de l'écosystème et du territoire
de 130 m² 25 postes de travail ou encore
une salle de réunion pour les
utilisateurs du 50 comores king ce
nouveau mode de travail présente
plusieurs avantages qu au niveau de
qualité de vie en est quand même
beaucoup mieux en télétravail puisqu'on
travaille proche de chez nous et donc au
niveau du stress et tout ça ça réduit
vraiment ces difficultés là et puis on
est on est bien mieux quand on rentre le
soir à la maison
en fait moi je suis indépendant je
pourrais être encore une fois tout seul
j'ai bien sûr les relations avec mes
clients mais ça ne suffit pas en fait
donc je viens chercher ici une vraie un
vrai un vrai lien communautaire puisque
un simple bureau un esprit collaboratif
des valeurs essentielles pour cet espace
de coworking situées en zone rurale
le but c'est de garder une taille
humaine aussi qui permet de maintenir ce
lien et cette convivialité
j'ai pas d'ambition
d'agrandissement ou de multiplication
des sites
par contre j'ai une ambition
d'accompagnement sur la création
d'autres espaces de coworking et
d'autres tiers lieu que ce soit sur mon
territoire ou sur le reste du territoire
national durant les prochaines semaines
la ministre du travail mme muriel
pénicaud va multiplier les déplacements
en ile de france sur la question du
télétravail et des espaces de coworking